hey what's going on in still burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday January 15 2018 what's going on
how are ya how are you I am in San
Francisco it's still Sunday the second
half has just begun the saints go
marching in verse the Minnesota Vikings
this Saints was my pick this weekend I
loved drew Brees going into Minnesota
and [ __ ] having everybody crying at
the [ __ ] Mall of America by the end
of the game and so far the Vikings are
up 17 to nothing although I think they
just [ __ ] went three and out cold
case key to just got put down on his
[ __ ] keister well sing well you never
know what's gonna happen you know I mean
look look what the [ __ ] Jaguars the
Jag was what just came right out gave
the Steelers the old right there Fred
all of a sudden they're running back
twist his ankle right I don't see I
can't put any weight on it man right
then all of a sudden the Steelers come
roar and [ __ ] back and I'm sitting
there going this game's over the
Pittsburgh Steelers it's in Pittsburgh
this [ __ ] is over
no way
what the [ __ ] his name Bryce bortles I
can't by the way I can't keep up with
these [ __ ] names from the 90s okay
the cases the Bryce the Bolton's the
[ __ ] I don't know you know a lot of
comics have done bits about it but you
know back when it was like you know Bill
Bob [ __ ] Steve Joe greatest
quarterback of all [ __ ] time at one
point was named Joe you know Joe Namath
Joe Montana Joe Theismann Joe [ __ ]
Blake bortles
like you know whatever I'm just I'm an
old crabby [ __ ] man
I guess the 90s it was really big to
name your kid after a cname considering
all the quarterbacks right current
carson case it's like did Roger Clemens
[ __ ] all these women nobody did that he
had like [ __ ] nine kids and he could
Cody Kyle kunti Chris Wright they were
all case they were all case yeah why
would you have them have their own
identity let's [ __ ] have their name
be about your [ __ ] career what do you
mean you want to be a veterinarian
get the [ __ ] out there pick up baseball
and throw some hate sorry that was my
impression of what it's like inside
their household like I have any idea all
right I have nothing against the Clemens
family I love Roger Clemens
you know [ __ ] did some great things
with the Red Sox before he went to
Toronto well we let him go right then he
[ __ ] jumped on that poor police horse
Jesus Christ you know that horse was
wishing it was a [ __ ] Clydesdale when
he got on his goddamn back I'm just in a
bad mood cuz I'm in San Francisco right
I [ __ ] came here yesterday and no guy
has even looked at me no I came here
yesterday and it was sunny up one of the
rare sunny beautiful days and San
Francisco when it is sunny out when the
weather is nice can [ __ ] with any city
I'll even say in North America forget
about the continental United States
including Alaska Hawaii and some of our
tributaries like [ __ ] Puerto Rico
there I sake [ __ ] with any city ok
however on the usual cloudy rainy day
this place there's a misery to this
[ __ ] place this it's cold wet air
blowing against you as you walk up yet
another [ __ ] hill you know nothing is
ever down a hill it's always up a hill
around a corner to an even steeper Hill
you know and they still have all that
and Papas you know although leaves are
brown hippie vibe going out here a
little bit even all the evil people from
[ __ ] Silicon Valley which I still
never know quite where that is
it's somewhere down near like San Jose I
just don't know where it begins and
where it ends but silicone to make in my
level of intellect the amount of books
that I've read in life silicone to me is
and will always be what's in fake
titties so you know I don't know what
they're doing I actually flew up here
rented a helicopter and flew up here
with a couple people had a great [ __ ]
time picked up a couple of hours and we
went by this giant building that was
this huge circle and I was like what the
[ __ ] is that that looks like I don't
know it looks like like the Pentagon if
it was groovy man right like what is
that and my buddy guests he goes is
probably maybe it's Apple I never seen a
building like it it was just a total
circle then in the middle there was like
all of this like it looked like a jungle
in the middle you know and if you look
down you could see the employees
screaming and wave and don't get me out
of here he's still alive Steve is still
alive I think that's what it said I but
I was you know too busy focusing on not
hitting somebody else while I was up
there it turns out it was the Apple
building very impressive bear even
[ __ ] impressive structure and then we
went right by Stanford and saw that
Stadium I buddy was hitting me with
trivia before we got there he goes I
went to a game I went to a Super Bowl he
claimed it was the only Super Bowl ever
played at a college Stadium or something
like that which isn't true because they
played a bunch at the Rose Bowl and also
a 2-lane maybe he said the last one
played at a college Stadium was at that
I forget what it was don't blame him
blame me for not remembering and I was
able to guess that I said was the 49ers
Dolphins at Stanford Stadium only
because I had recently read that that's
where they played that game and because
I got that right he then had to be like
what was the score I was like I don't
know but Fulton
Walker took a kickoff back for the first
time in Super Bowl history it's like 35
10 so anyways we [ __ ] land at San
Francisco International Airport
which it's so it's so much different you
know when you and when you actually get
to see how cool it [ __ ] it looks when
you're sitting in the back of the tube
you know and you're just looking out the
back just pray and you know just please
get this thing on the [ __ ] ground
it's different when you come up there
it's [ __ ] amazing it's expensive as
[ __ ] but it's amazing right
so we land everything's going great and
I ended up doing this thing with what is
it the San Francisco sketch fest and I
did this what was it the who's the guy
from Cuba Castro the Castro theatre with
Kevin Pollak and we just went out and
sort of an interview just riff and
[ __ ] around and then people came up
and asked questions afterwards I want to
thank everybody it showed up was like
1:00 in the afternoon
all of these people showed up it was a
great time and Kevin's just the greatest
[ __ ] dude ever and we actually I got
to do a scene with them in a movie
coming up called front runner it's
coming up this year we had a great time
doing that and you know San Francisco
why in a bad mood build the South sounds
great it's all great it's all [ __ ]
great then I get to my hotel
of course I show up right and the lady
takes my driver's license I forgot to
not just show it to her like she took
the driver's license right so then she
starts clicking on a keyboard I say hey
dude can you do me a favor Keane can you
not type any personal information on a
license if she got all this [ __ ]
attitude she goes I am NOT I will tell
you what I'm typing in and Bumble and
his whole [ __ ] you know snap to the
12 to the six whatever the [ __ ] kids
say I want to be like lady lady you're
not gonna tell me what you're gonna do
I'm gonna tell you what you're not gonna
do you [ __ ] [ __ ]
but of course I can't say that you know
I can't say that do I don't know what
the [ __ ] happened to customer service
but her [ __ ] attitude the way she
talked to me it was like I told her how
to parent her kid so then she looks me
up of course they don't [ __ ] have me
down cuz I probably miss communicating
when I was gonna come up here or anyways
I just didn't say a [ __ ] word right
and then she went out of her way and
actually got me you know I shouldn't get
it on me out of the way she [ __ ] did
her job [ __ ] her still [ __ ] her sir I'm
gonna tell you one but like what enough
I felt like I was getting booked I just
I I [ __ ] I don't understand what has
happened to customer service so then I
was just like alright alright [ __ ]
whatever alright and then this hotel
turns out they don't have the two things
that I need in a hotel the only two
[ __ ] things I need other than a
[ __ ] door that doesn't open up out
into the parking lot in other words I'm
not staying in a motel okay and all I
need is some sort of gym in an ironing
board that's it
this hotel has neither has neither has a
little steam [ __ ] machine I don't
want to steam my [ __ ] clothes I
practice my drum [ __ ] but I'm on the
road I bring a little practice pad and
after all these years of trying to find
a [ __ ] table that fits right it the
ironing board was there the whole time
he just plays standing up okay and you
can adjust it down if it's not high
enough he just put a couple of towels
underneath and then it's at the height
you need it to be they don't [ __ ]
have one and then lastly I went to go
get a burrito and I [ __ ] up like San
Francisco makes the best burritos right
they got the best break perfected them I
don't know where they came from I
believe France invented the burrito I'm
not sure so this is [ __ ] I'm not going
to name the burrito place but evidently
they got a great spot in the mission and
I'm all the way down near the [ __ ]
touristy area where they got like rides
to Alcatraz I'm like I'm not [ __ ]
going all the way out there I want to
watch both these [ __ ] football games
and no one behold I find that there's
there's a guy there's a one that's in on
everybody's top ten list that makes a
[ __ ] burrito
in the mission but also has another
location down near the fishermen place
right the wharf down here so I'm like
alright well I know it's probably not
gonna be as good as the original because
that's the original oven and blah blah
blah blah blah so I [ __ ] go to the
new this obviously the second one that
they opened I show up right and there's
like [ __ ] I don't know a group of
four in front of me in a group of two in
front of me and you would have thought
the amount of time it took them to order
a [ __ ] burrito you would have thought
that they were trying to like you know
it was like war time and they were
trying to catch the last flight out
before the in you know the impending
regime or whatever it's gonna send them
to a [ __ ] labor camp that's like how
long they were negotiating this and what
kills me is these four people it took
for [ __ ] ever then the two people
behind him who had enough time to
[ __ ] go on YouTube find out what's in
a burrito go to a [ __ ] supermarket
buy the [ __ ] and cook one that's the
amount of time they had it they step up
to the register it's their moment of
truth to order a burrito and they will
start looking at the menu [ __ ]
ridiculous [ __ ] ridiculous so I get
up there what do you want give me the
original burrito chicken chips and salsa
in a water to go cash thank you step
aside over how hard is that
you know what it is is somewhere in the
last century it became illegal to punch
somebody in the back of the head when
they were taken too long in a line and
now everybody they just you know they
just a little too comfortable they're
just a little too comfortable so I'm
standing there and you know now I'm
behind the [ __ ] couple that you know
over at the salsa line salsa line salsa
salsa line and I'm behind them again and
it's taking them forever to get [ __ ]
salsa
the [ __ ] looking around and they're
looking at other people it's like use
your [ __ ] brain mild medium hot the
[ __ ] touchdown Sates
oh when them saints go marching in but a
puppy dah dah dah doo Oh Oh plenty of
time left
no there isn't what am I talking about
thought that was [ __ ] 118 into the
third quarter well I guess there's
plenty of time left right this is the
way the game is played nowadays it's
like do they go for two here there's
only a quarter in a minute 13 left kick
the [ __ ] extra point yeah Jesus
Christ that guy just had a soul patch on
the back of his head well you know tough
you have to be to have that cuz some
whiskey's just how hard it would be to
not tell that guy how [ __ ] annoying
that it's like dude I just want to
[ __ ] can you just grow it out or
shave it off
alright touchdown Saints touch to my
prediction lives this is such a
disturbing commercial where this guy
falls off the cruise ship this is one of
my biggest [ __ ] fears in life you
don't I mean just being in the [ __ ]
ocean praying for hypothermia to set in
before someone thinks something comes up
to you and just takes a bite out of you
can you imagine when you see that
[ __ ] shark fin just break the water
you know and you know you smell the
thing
[ __ ] wild animals you could smell
them from a mile away to the point I
don't understand how they're able to
kill anybody you know you didn't see
ever go to the [ __ ] zoo when you just
smell those goddamn lions I guess
everything stinks out there you know
anyways then they just leave the guy in
the [ __ ] ocean [ __ ] really bothers
me
there's got to be somebody complaining
about that
you know once a year that seems to
happen or every couple of years like
somebody goes on a honeymoon and their
spouse [ __ ] falls overboard you know
I got to look that up how many [ __ ]
times what are you what are the odds are
the odds higher on a honeymoon or after
you've been married for a while like how
many times somebody has like [ __ ]
thrown a spouse overboard you know and
if it's anywhere near the number that I
think it is I want to know why it
doesn't have its own hashtag I think we
need to start a hashtag on Twitter let
me just do [ __ ] three seconds of
research here spouse how do you spell
spouse I just felt spouse spouse what
would I look up here spouse dead cruise
ship significant other question mark
[Laughter]
[Music]
when a passenger dies at sea what you
need to know oh my god what do they do
do they have a burial at sea you know
with the Carnival Cruise Line flag and
they try to make it look official it's
just sitting there looking at [ __ ]
Gilligan and gopher it's other guys
named gopher look I became like a
senator husband pleads not guilty and
wife's cruise ship killing oh my god
geez if they if they figure out can you
imagine that well that's that's just
cruel and unusual punishment bad enough
you killed somebody the fact that you
would send them to that of a lonely
brutal death a Utah man who allegedly
brutally murdered his wife last month
while on board in Alaska oh we killed
her on board
all right well Jesus this and [ __ ]
serious music dude who composed that ate
this guy killed his wife this guy killed
his wife on a [ __ ] cruise ship and
this guy just we need we need music for
that and that guy he just come I can't
get back to the fade in that well that
was what the Jimmy Page army of [ __ ]
guitars there if you imagine that you
wanted to write the next stairway to
heaven and now you're just writing
[ __ ] music you know that fits people
dying on a [ __ ] cruise ship
okay this dude is accused of
first-degree murder in the death of his
39 year old wife she must have [ __ ]
choked during shuffleboard or something
I am sorry
Kenneth's wife was found dead in her
cruise ship cabin on July 25th after the
couple had a domestic dispute oh my god
did you know they should throw this guy
overboard Jesus Christ said blood was
spread throughout the room on multiple
surfaces whose immediately detained by
ship security and a witness said that
the the defendant allegedly told him she
would not stop laughing at me Jesus
Christ what the fool she ridiculing him
you know it's funny if this was the
other way around I think the woman goes
free if if she just said he was fat
shaming her like she put on some baby
weight or something like that and you
see wouldn't stop laughing at me and I
just made me feel like I was small each
year over 4,000 men laugh at their
recently not pregnant why's causing them
to feel bad about themselves okay he had
been acting terrible all night the
source claimed adding at some point that
evening East yeah she wouldn't stay
somebody not stop laughing at you as you
go for a walk
what if Wow what was going lucky if that
guy is not just a straight-up [ __ ]
psycho
you know like what the [ __ ] was going on
how many movies could you make out of
that relationship like if that guy never
did anything wrong in his life and she
was just so [ __ ] sadistic sadistic
and it had so gotten into his [ __ ]
head that her just laughing at him he
that he [ __ ] snapped like that you
know I'm just playing the other side
just playing devil's advocate here
interception so when those saints go
marching in get that a dee da ba da boo
how annoying am I to the [ __ ] person
next to me case keenum case case Andrew
those are the quarterbacks it used to be
Joe verse Phillip Roger verse Terry what
was some of the great rivalry names
Danvers Kenny maybe Dan Fouts versus
Kenny Anderson and that [ __ ] freezing
ball oh he definitely stepped out about
you could see it right there that's
exactly what happened there you can't
see any grade between the white line
Case Keenum got out a giant iPad he's
gonna play a little Donkey Kong put on a
hat
there you go hugs all around like the
game has been won on the Saints side is
it me to the Saints uniforms look a
little cheap I don't know what's going
on did they take some stripe away in
this shirt it looks like they should be
playing on half a field inside a hockey
arena am i right drew Bray's he's got
the ball he hands it off and a guy
immediately is tackled what a waste of a
play 102 to go in the [ __ ] third
quarter you want me announced the rest
of the third quarter for you some of you
guys like when I do this [ __ ] all right
number 29 he's upset
what is he upset about I don't know but
a guy with [ __ ] night-vision glasses
is talking to him listen I just got from
the gun range I didn't see what happened
but I believe in you 29 what the [ __ ] is
he doing out there that's a running back
number is they maybe he's mad at maybe
he's mad at case get off my case keenum
sorry jubblies drops back to pass over
the [ __ ] middle when those sakes get
a [ __ ] first down why do I give a
[ __ ] about this game it's literally just
cuz I told Paul virzi that I thought the
Saints are gonna win that I need this to
happen to fill me up in life because I'm
a married guy you know in the
compliments you know their honor their
honor oh we're on I'm on like a
compliment ration I get one a season and
there's only one season in LA I used to
get for a year when I lived in New York
now I'm out in LA I get about one how do
you get that job as water water guy like
how do you know who's [ __ ] thirsty
nobody ever points their mouth you just
kind of walk up you stick it you know
all right I swear to God the black guy
in this commercial looks like they stuck
his head on like an eight-year-olds body
although I do like this commercial bill
nobody gives a [ __ ] most people aren't
even watching this no they don't even oh
you're talking about you're literally
doing comic commentary for a [ __ ]
YouTube video that doesn't exist while
they're listening to your podcast get
back on the [ __ ] game here
[ __ ] Steelers what are the what is
what this deal is how many times are
they gonna look past the opponent that
week that's that's that's what they say
it out there they're saying that they
focus too much on the New England
Patriots because you know who's kidding
who they beat the Patriots earlier this
year you know that was a touch I don't
know you know what I don't understand
about you know whether it's a catch or
whether it's not a catch is the fact
that the ground can't cause a fumble
if you're running but if you're it can
cut it can cause an incomplete pass said
how it works
I don't know I have no idea but I like
that commercial I just saw that guy was
like practice and speed skating like in
his living room that'll be like the
latest thing people will get rather than
reading about nutrition they'll
literally spend like [ __ ] 10 grand on
that thing and then they'll have some
sort of app where they can project it
under their TV where they can you can be
you know in different speed skating
arenas around the [ __ ] world I saw
this picture today on the internet it
just [ __ ] it made me feel so goddamn
old it was this woman right where's that
place where people go to vacation right
it's like the ocean looks absolutely
perfect and there's East these grass
like these huts and they hover out over
the water you know one tsunami and
everybody's dead right but it looks like
absolute paradise okay in the picture of
this woman she's in a thong right
leaning on one leg so her butt cheek
sticking out and she's looking at the
huts and over her head she's making you
know those that stupid thing will you
make the heart with your hands she's
doing that you know and that it made me
feel so [ __ ] old it's like what did
it happen to just go into a [ __ ]
unbelievable place and just geeking out
and taking a picture of yourself and you
have that look on your face like you
can't believe you they're like she
literally used that paradise to enhance
her whole [ __ ] like I don't know what
the word is her harness I don't know
this selfie just it just makes everybody
act like a douche who doesn't know how
to behave when they get their own show
in other words they behave like myself
what's going on I stepped out of bounce
eight yards he picked up eight yards
I'll tell you right now you know what I
tell you who's gonna make a big a lot of
[ __ ] money whoever owns the Kleenex
store in the Mall of America it's my
prediction that every one of these
Minnesota fans are going to [ __ ] in at
the end of this game are they're all
going to go down to the mall
all over America and they gotta go into
the Kleenex store they're gonna get
their own [ __ ] you know Kleenex with
their own initial on it cuz everybody's
[ __ ] special now and you can take a
selfie but how sad you are actually no
it would be amazing is if the Vikings go
to the Superbowl
okay and they play a home game oh when
the saints go marching in they're down
to the [ __ ] two yard line
you guys like Pete fountain huh put on
the old grape bonnet I love Pete
fountain [ __ ] always had a killer
drummer right
I played the [ __ ] out of the clarinet
you know what I mean and he's never had
any sexual harassment scandals um
anyways plowing ahead here Wow Jesus
Christ this [ __ ] guy this guy's hurt
now what happened what happened to the
guy does he gotta go inside the tent
well thank god there's an 80 year old
bald white guy to help him off the field
the dude was so short he couldn't even
lean on him he's probably gonna have a
separated shoulder by the time he gets
over to that little [ __ ] little pop
tent they put him in hey I think I found
the mp3 player that now that I'm seeing
this poor bastard with the umbilical
cord hanging and I'm getting out of the
Apple world right as I said that that
weirdo just stared at me in the galaxy
commercial like he knew I was gonna
[ __ ] do it I'm gonna get a new MP I'm
gonna go with one of those Sony's you
know and I want to tell you guys the
exact model so you can be like dude oh
my god really you're gonna buy them yeah
I am I am cuz I have a bunch of music
but I didn't get on [ __ ] Apple and
those round building [ __ ] okay but the
forest in the middle where they
reeducate their employees that want to
ask for more money or maybe pay the poor
bastards that put together their
products
so they don't jump to their [ __ ]
deaths how crazy would be if they still
advertised on this podcast after that
yeah I want to [ __ ] get out of that
world I want to I still want to use this
[ __ ] but I don't like how they are
they're like [ __ ] this is our [ __ ]
over here I [ __ ] only works with our
with our [ __ ] none of our [ __ ] works
with other people's [ __ ] you wanna use
our shake you gotta buy our other [ __ ]
to use our [ __ ] [ __ ] people's other [ __ ]
we're gonna [ __ ] own everything I
don't say what is your problem how many
billions of dollars to you I swear to
God at that point I know what promoted
like that
I know promoter like that he wants to
make all the money you know it's not
enough that he's making the most money
he wants to make all the money and it
actually gives him joy when when other
people when other people's uh you know
other promoters in his town are not
doing well he'll just say oh did you
hear about so and so they books on saw a
guy took a bath and I'd be like I bet
that makes you happy I [ __ ] la me
anyways I guess I never gave you guys a
hashtag for the cruise ships once you
guys come up with one uh here comes the
tent the pop up tent
Dick's Sporting good all right let's see
a dick what happened did he hit you left
ball you're right ball all right we're
gonna freeze it here we're gonna spoon
it do a little [ __ ] and put a little
desenex on it and I think he'd be all
right
all right drew brees hands the ball off
and he guy runs into everybody evidently
there was supposed to be a hole there
you know when I was a kid I thought that
running backs rather than running around
the outside the reason why they ran in
the middle is cuz they thought they'd
get famous for trying to do something so
impossible what do you guys think it's
gonna happen here actually you already
know I say that they're gonna score on
third goal right unless they try and run
it three [ __ ] times how about a
little play-action fake here drove for
the love of [ __ ] Christ
oh by the way could congratulations to
Liverpool huh
Liverpool be [ __ ] Man City
guess you guys didn't realize I've been
paying attention a little bit to the
Premier League that soccer for everybody
here in North America Drew Brees throws
that there when them Saints Go marchin
it's [ __ ] seventeen two [ __ ]
thirteen all right okay Case Keenum Case
Keenum he's on the case keenum they must
do a bunch of [ __ ] like that right any
time uh you know they always have the
punch right you must do a bunch of those
things Jesus Christ this is that's
becoming a tale of two halves it comes
through Brees he's gonna break their
hearts I'll tell you right now then that
there right now the last ride on the
roller coaster at the Mall of America is
happening there's an overall sadness
that is going to descend on that mall
right now there's a bunch of people that
do not give a [ __ ] okay two white guys
trying to do a cool handshake they don't
know what they just did there some sort
of jerk-off [ __ ] motion by Drew Brees
is he gave the okay sign you know well
these are the times is it okay that I'm
stroking your dick I think that that's
what that meant I think that was very
progressive by Drew Brees all right if
you could tell I'm doing this thing
early and I have yet to get any of the
advertising I don't have any [ __ ] any
other questions or anything so at some
point I'm going to have to [ __ ] hit
pause or I could text my [ __ ] guy
here to send me the [ __ ] right that
could happen that could happen right let
me hit pause you don't listen this
[ __ ] crept or do you Johnny Oduya the
[ __ ] is going on with the Blackhawks
this year I mean I mean I gotta hit
pause and not to put you through this
[ __ ] alright I'm back oh you know what I
was gonna say is if Minnesota wins this
game and then goes to the Superbowl and
I'm actually a Vikings fan from way back
in the day to be honest with you I don't
know why I'm just being a douche right
now like I said I just predicted this
upset I don't care if the Vikings win
first down 13:02
to go in the game he's not he's not
like they didn't just give up 14 points
in a row what every [ __ ] guy now acts
like they just reinvented football look
at this
all those people blocked for him and
then when there was finally a [ __ ]
guy who could tackle him he did and this
guy gets up like he's Steve ever see Jim
Brown get up [ __ ] Noddin oh the old
man this is this is what you sound like
it the closer you get to death you know
he's like well why is it my weight used
to be Case Keenum he is on a strict no
passing diet right now they saw that
last one they're like [ __ ] this guy just
hand it off now why ain't you nodding
how come you nod nod no one got stuff
for anything goddamn lying
everybody anybody makes a good play that
point at the name in the back of the
jersey any time they [ __ ] don't make
a play they're looking for a flag or
they run off the field anyways if I can
get through this goddamn point if
Minnesota actually goes to the goddamn
Super Bowl
it's a [ __ ] home game alright
everything there is purple there's no
way you got to have like a prince themed
halftime show do you think he would have
played it think he would have company
yeah what I had to have Prince come back
look at that [ __ ] throw Case Keenum
shaking off the interception the Saints
say it's not a catch they say it's not a
catch right says oh my god I can't even
deal how [ __ ] great I am it's driving
me crazy
Case Keenum everybody stops shouting
settle down this is a great [ __ ]
throw oh he just drops it right in there
I don't know a little bit of wobbly
there in the end he caught it but did he
catch it long enough Case Keenum gets
the aisle they got oh not in time not in
time the challenge flag this degenerate
gamblin looking head coach his [ __ ]
wife probably cries herself to sleep
that's such a terrible thing to say why
would I say that
alright he's on the ground he has it he
has it he has it he has it he still has
it if they call this not a [ __ ] catch
look at this [ __ ] alright there you go
that's a catch he's got it he's got it
he's got it he's got it he's got it he's
got it
what are they gonna look at jesus
[ __ ] christ how long do you have to
have it oh my god now I gotta see this
replay 58 [ __ ] time yeah yeah as you
see right there now he has it against
his navel and his [ __ ] a happy trail
um this guy pleading his case
take back your red hanky all right I
know you got you guys I don't think you
want to [ __ ] Liz I've really limited
my goddamn audience here let's talk
about [ __ ] let's limit it even more
and I'll talk to my six British fans
over there man City
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] Jesus Christ it was like
a full [ __ ] bottle of water and it's
Evian too and I [ __ ] hate that [ __ ]
Evian there's minerals in it yeah I can
taste it it tastes [ __ ] weird did the
water rush through a plastic Rock why
does it taste so [ __ ] awful I [ __ ]
hate everyone um anyways this must be
like the best bottled water it tastes
like [ __ ]
Auden how do I know it's from the French
Alps I have to ring anything Poland
Spring Dasani smart water I'll drink
that box water I don't give a [ __ ] even
though it tastes like you're drinking
out of a shoe that [ __ ] wet cardboard
I know it's better for the environment
but Jesus Christ oh you know what's the
worst was when you a little kid you
drank out of the garden hose and you
didn't realize it was sitting in the Sun
you had that [ __ ] hot blast of stale
[ __ ] water they'd probably been in
there for a week
Jesus Christ think you know that taking
out your [ __ ] small intestine alright
let's look up this man city [ __ ]
alright man city man city lost for 2/3
to Liverpool now now for those of you
who living in the United States a murder
of murca man City evidently was [ __ ]
undefeated the whole year I guess that's
really difficult it's difficult to do in
any sport but I wasn't sure with soccer
just seems like you score one goal and
the game's over but I will tell you
lately they've been four to three
seven goals you got to love that got a
[ __ ] love that they lost a Liverpool
home of the [ __ ] Beatles that's all I
know it's all they know about that [ __ ]
oh let's talk about let's talk about
Donnie Donnie [ __ ] case Kate I'm sacked
I know he got the ball up Donal [ __ ]
Trump I gotta say something man that was
a low that is a low point in modern
United States history and that's [ __ ]
saying something you just can't you know
you know you just can't for everything
to not even apologize hey you know I
should've said it that way but bah bah
bah bah that was just a [ __ ] like I
don't know what people still sticking by
the guy what he's detailing like it is
all right this is number two guy number
four it's gonna hold the ball the little
skinny guy he kicks the ball right down
the [ __ ] middle it was a one-eyed
one-horned flying
what is the Minnesota Vikings what is
this Saints guy bitching about now what
does he complain him I'll tell you right
now okay if I [ __ ] that [ __ ] up not
she would have said no catch yes you
would have
yes you would have you just like my wife
you're just like my [ __ ] wife Jesus
you know you're fat when you can see a
man tits under the windbreaker well he
was saying the guy was down alright
nobody cares Bill this is one of the
worst podcast I've ever done I apologize
okay and I'm sure you guys will let me
know all right
oh so the burrito ended up getting like
it just sucked wasn't wrapped tight or I
guess I'm supposed to keep it in the
foil I have no [ __ ] idea and then the
chicken was like overcooked
you know this is what happens this is
what happens when you go to a city and
you go you know what these people are
known for this and then you as a tourist
don't know where to go and you just go
out and get one and then you go back to
your city with the the wrong information
saying I went there their burritos
sucked it didn't say I could make a
better breeder than that you know that's
like you know people go to Chicago New
York and they say that their pizza sucks
it's like well who did you hang out with
were you with people from the city did
they tell you what a [ __ ] to go well you
know what I wanted to look up because
people are sitting there say now they
got it when peach [ __ ] Donald Trump
and it's just like well they impeach
Bill Clinton he got impeached I was like
holy [ __ ] he's gonna have to leave and
then he he didn't he just why didn't
Bill Clinton leave and then I was just
right in peach right that should get me
he Spelling peached there you go
impeached if Bill Clinton why did he
finish gave Bill Clinton was impeached
why did he finish up I don't stand how
he could have been a peach but he did
not leave office all right being a peach
doesn't guarantee the person in peach
has to leave office here's some
historical examples the problem with you
question is he was not impeached in a
way to have to leave office I see you
really don't understand the difference
between impeachment and having to leave
office now you didn't have to be that
[ __ ] kunti about it not true he
wasn't peached for a public official in
peach well this is just people arguing
Bill Clinton was acquitted the Senate
did not reach the two-thirds majority
needed to fully process his impeachment
to further break it down Clinton was
impeached by the house on two charges
the first being perjury the second being
obstruction of justice following this he
was acquitted by the Senate the
impeachment process takes place in two
steps first a president has to stick a
cigar in somebody's [ __ ] no that's
right
first the president has to be impeached
in the House of Representatives that is
the equivalent of an indictment ah then
the president is
tried in the Senate with the Chief
Justice of the United States presiding
oh this is why all the lefties are
saying we got to [ __ ] kill these
elections in October so we can get Trump
out I was like what the [ __ ] are they
talking about so then they could
actually indict him in the house and
then impeach him in the Senate it
requires a two-thirds vote of the Senate
to remove an impeachment you think if he
got impeached right if it went to the
Senate and he got impeached like I
actually think that he would leave
before they took the vote he would get
on his own [ __ ] plane and he would
just leave and he'd be on the like just
so his ego could handle it like you know
you're not gonna come walking in here
and have me pack up my [ __ ] and have me
escorted out like I just get fired at
you know some [ __ ] corporation all
right I haven't been I don't take the
amount of time that I take to comb my
hair over the top of my [ __ ] head to
be treated this way
all right so evidently they [ __ ]
didn't think the guy was down I'm
literally commentating a game that you
already know the results of that you're
not watching this is the stupidest
[ __ ] thing I've ever done all right
I'll be honest with you I'm just I'm
[ __ ] lonely okay I just felt like
talking to somebody can you guys just be
there for me
all right the [ __ ] [ __ ] guy did
his goddamn job he hit it twice hey how
about a round of applause for the person
who's making the field goal kickers
helmets now they finally you know they
gave him like two bars you know remember
back in the day they just had that like
Fred Cox Joe Theismann all those guys
just had that one bar across the front
of their [ __ ] I mean I don't know I
don't know how those people survived all
right you know in it this is gonna be a
mercy pause right here I'm gonna just
wait for all the information to come
from my [ __ ] podcast so I can
actually do this okay yes we'll send
over in five getting advertising now all
right I still got advertising all right
I'll talk to you in two seconds here all
right I'm back and I got all the
materials I need here by the way all
when to say it's they [ __ ] scored
again
they're up by one point that's where I
am in the game
they just Vikings just got a pass
interference call with number 19 or some
[ __ ] on the Vikings who has the smallest
shoulder pads I've ever seen in my life
remember the 80s how big [ __ ]
shoulder pads were what do they make
those things out of now I guess if
everybody has small ones then it's a
[ __ ] it's a fair game oh by the way
so basically what happened with Bill
Clinton was he got indicted in the House
of Representatives and then when it went
to the Senate they needed two-thirds of
the vote and none of the Democrats voted
to impeach him so that's how he got off
the Liberals looked the other way with
the sexual harassment and you know and
it's all just politics it's not like one
side is better than the other if it was
a Republican they would have voted the
you know they all would have voted the
exact [ __ ] opposite way except maybe
one or two [ __ ] actually decent human
beings and the result but so Bill
Clinton got acquitted but he did lose
his license to practice law because of
that and that [ __ ] unbelievable
unfuckable what if oh one of the hardest
things I think is to become a lawyer
just all like like trying to pass the
bar and all of that you go through all
of that [ __ ] and then what do you do you
stick a cigar in some [ __ ] woman's
[ __ ] that isn't your wife and then you
lie about it and then all that studying
goes right out the window
Jesus Christ I love cigars and I love
women but I'm telling you if I learned
anything you got to keep them separate
all right okay let's do some advertising
here uh three reads all right honey
that's the name of this new company
there was an amazing free browser
extension called honey honey could you
that millions of millions of people use
every day to save money honey is the
word the world's most popular
money-saving browser add-on it works on
Chrome Fire
Fox Safari all the major browsers and
it's always free I have no idea what it
is no it's this money-saving browser
okay it only takes two clicks to add oh
honey
to your browser when it starts working
in the back it starts working in the
background right away when you shop
honey
scans and tests millions of coupon codes
all over the internet to find you the
biggest discount on everything you buy
online oh that's cool no more googling
random coupon codes that don't end up
working yeah I was trying to buy oh they
[ __ ] Minnesota hit a field goal Case
Keenum let him write down the goddamn
feels a minute twenty-nine left and they
got drew brees oh when the saints
anyways I was trying to some [ __ ] old
lady can't even get up for it I tried to
buy a Jersey for my nephew and I filled
out where I lived all my credit card
information all of this [ __ ] and then
when I hit processed it like a it's not
in stock and then they kept all my
information to pricks so why don't you
try out honey but here's the best part
of it whenever you're ready to check out
honey
automatically applies the best coupon to
your current there is no reason not to
add honey to your browser it's free it
will always save you cash on everything
you were going to buy anyways yeah this
is no-brainer if you're not using honey
when you shop you're missing out on free
money it's not really free money you're
throwing away money is what you're doing
and honey to your browser for free right
now at join honey dot-com / bird that's
joined honey dot-com / / the Saints do
not return minute twenty nine to go how
the [ __ ] did that kick off take no time
but I caught it that must've been a
split second right simply faith ain't
bill stop using her [ __ ] as a humidor
simply safe
studies show that security systems deter
burglars it's a fact but there is still
a burglar burglary every eight seconds
in America burglars don't give up just
because someone's house has a security
system
they find a house that isn't protected
that's why securing your home with
simply faith is truly is truly a
necessity simply safe is ridiculously
smart and its senses and its sensors
will protect every point of access to
your home plus if a burglar so much as
tries to break in an ear-shattering
siren will let them know that the place
that the police are already on their way
well let's hope it's not your [ __ ]
old neighbor checking in on you they
might have a heart attack through Brees
do Brees incomplete best of all simply
saves 24/7 monitoring is just $14.99 a
month to get ear-splitting security
they'll never lock you in your long-term
contract with simply faith you'll even
get a 60 day money back guarantee so
there's no reason not to try it today
protect your home and family was simply
safe by going to simply save burg calm
today that simply save burg calm to
order today your simply save home
security system simply save Bure calm si
MP Li that's how you spell simply simply
safe burg calm why is it always
ear-splitting why can't they have it
like just why don't they just have it
sound like somebody really tough you
know like somebody breaks in you just
have some guy you know really deep voice
[ __ ] get my good right
that wasn't a tough voice you know what
I mean somebody just says some crazy
[ __ ] right you said in the creepiest
voice ever you just whisper that have
that that's your alarm I'm gonna murder
you
right or maybe this is what it is baby
it [ __ ] the alarm goes to your phone
and then you see the person breaking in
and then you start talking all this [ __ ]
like you're in there and you're crazy
you'll be all brave because you're not
home I see you and your green shirt you
[ __ ] I will light you on fire
you know some crazy [ __ ] said that we
all write stamps calm everybody here's a
New Year's resolution you can actually
keep ad stand stop ad stance calm to
your business and save a ton of time and
money this year I use stamps calm any
nice [ __ ] defensive play I use stamps
calm
anytime I'm sending out my posters and
I'm gonna [ __ ] myself out after shows
and deal with Cougars groping me which
course goes unchecked because they're
women and they're not held accountable
for their actions plus stamps calm has
postage discounts you can't get at the
post office not to mention it's a
fraction of the cost of those super
expensive postage meters stamps calm
sends you a digital scale that
automatically calculates exact postage
you will never overpay or under pay for
poachers postage again I use stamps calm
B Club because I already told you I and
Ike if I can figure it out you can
figure out because I'm a [ __ ]
and right now you too can enjoy the
stamps comes service with a special
offer that includes a four week trial
plus Drew Brees throwing [ __ ] postage in
a digital scale ready for a happier New
Year ready for a half of your New Year
go to stamp stock on click on the
microphone on top of the homepage and
type in Burpee URR that stamps.com enter
birth all right number three Bobby a
bear they brought him back from the
[ __ ] retirement his loosening up is
what he needs to weigh that number
he's [ __ ] loosening up his leg here to
kick a [ __ ] field goal which would
win it oh my god oh my god was my
prediction true these poor Viking fans
gonna get [ __ ] again are they gonna be
crying at the Mall of America how much
how many yards to see neat they need
like another 15 yards Oh uh-oh okay here
we go the Vikings are one play away
unless this guy comes in and just kits
like a [ __ ] 70 yarder oh you gotta
catch that you gotta catch that hey [ __ ]
you I want to throw it was right there
drew brees oh god the coach has on his
reading glasses he's already in the F
offseason he's gonna read catch her in
the Rye or some [ __ ] come on man come on
drew why do I give a [ __ ] the Vikings
have had a drought the Saints won in
2010 I just want to be right I said the
states are gonna win I apologize to
everybody in Minneapolis st. Paul Duluth
Oh No first down [ __ ] [ __ ] the Saints
oh my god I have to turn this up oh my
god he's in the guy's field goal rage Oh
No
you know it's funny I love Minneapolis I
don't want you people to be sad I was
just joking around
Oh Case Keenum puts a hat on takes it
off puts it on holds his head how am I
ever gonna talk to my loved ones again
holy [ __ ]
ten nine eight Jesus Christ drew what
are we doing I learned from Tony Romo
AUSA play clock you [ __ ] [ __ ]
all right forty seconds to go it's like
Jesus he's nonchalant I learned from
Tony Romo you wanted you want to kick it
with four seconds left I think it's four
seconds left because then you don't have
to kickoff
like that's how long a field goal takes
but with Tony Romo after he's done
bobbling it it probably takes 11 seconds
now come on he shits on Deion Sanders I
can give him a little [ __ ] rough time
I love Tony Romo by the way all right
practice T all right he kicked it okay I
put it into the net 37 seconds to go oh
my god it's just the Mall of America oh
god why didn't I invest in the Kleenex
store at the Mall of America one of the
dumbest things I ever did splits and
true pries [ __ ] picked it up it's a
catch oh I'm gonna talk so much [ __ ] de
Bercy I'm gonna talk so much [ __ ] to
virzi Dilla what did I say I called it
the ball was bobland no he got it he got
it did he catch it enough times for it
to be a kid and all that dog no no
that's not a catch the little tail was
hanging down the bottom scene I hear go
he goes all the [ __ ] drama this is
gonna be 20 [ __ ] minutes of this [ __ ]
alright I'm not even looking at this
goddamn game at this point that is not a
catch the Vikings come on you gotta
throw the challenge flag did the Vikings
coach just come from the gun range what
is with those goddamn glasses
you can see the point of the ball
touches the ground right there yeah it's
not a catch everybody knows it's not a
catch for the [ __ ] love of Christ all
right this is hilarious the first letter
that I got this week there's the water
guy now how did he know the guy wanted
the water down his back would that be
annoying tub of [ __ ] is the name of this
one dear Billy booze out I have been a
big fan of the podcast and you stand up
for several years now I'm writing you to
tell you that I owe you a lot oh Jesus
look at this it was about a year ago I
heard you first say that every now and
then you would look into the mirror and
call yourself a tub of [ __ ] I don't I
thought it was hilarious and it made me
realize I was a tub of [ __ ] as well yeah
look at that we're bonding um [ __ ]
sound iCloud preferences I don't know my
password and you won't give it you won't
give me a second chance so I don't want
to update it alright since last February
I have woken up every morning and told
myself that I am a tub of [ __ ] I made my
phone wallpaper a picture of me when I
was at my heaviest 255 so whenever i
unlock my phone there was a reminder of
the tub of [ __ ] I am and no longer want
to beat that's great
I'm proud to announce that I have lost
70 pounds in 11 months dude that's
awesome
and honestly I owe you big thanks for
giving me the motivation to do this
because of you and Joe Rogan probably
more Joe Rogan he's actually in shape I
have done a lot of things in the last
year that have taken me out of my
comfort zone you've been a great
inspiration in my life in many different
ways hope you and the lovely Neil and
the baby have a great 2018 from one tub
of [ __ ] to another go [ __ ] yourself well
that was just you know for all you guys
know that I wrote that there was really
no question there after further review
did he say that was a catch
what how the [ __ ] was that a cat she saw
the little cone of the ball Case Keenum
could not grow a beard god dammit he's
trying what the [ __ ] oh my god
everybody's got on there granny glasses
alright drew brees what's he gonna do
he's gonna get a hands off the [ __ ]
ball and nothing happens but he didn't
fumble it all right you guys want to
listen to this [ __ ] do you want to
listen to the sound of a bunch of 80,000
people if I already start crying to go
to the Mall of America if Iran the Mall
of America I would say free
rollercoaster rides for the entire month
well maybe for the week you know they
got to make that money over there can't
imagine how much oh my god how does this
always happen to the [ __ ] Vikings it
always happens to them when they're at
home everything with like fifteen and
one the dirty birds came in and it just
somehow came in and [ __ ] beat him
it's unreal done then they have a game
against like the [ __ ] Redskins or
something like that an 88 well they had
the game won and then it just [ __ ]
went away Jesus Christ all right here we
go
ba ba bears [ __ ] lining up for the
kick the kick is up wow it's good
oh no oh when the saints go marching in
oh my god the game is not over because
they got Case Keenum what the [ __ ] I'm
already typing in capital letters to
polliver see what the [ __ ] did I say
what did I say
all right let me turn this down what did
I do to the [ __ ] thing is there an
exit button exit holy [ __ ] [ __ ] I
can't I can't [ __ ] believe they came
back and won this game I know I just say
you know I don't know [ __ ] about
football she said it feeling sad a
feeling I was like drew brees he's like
third all-time passing he never gets the
respect he [ __ ] deserves I think he's
good I said it last week on the podcast
uh I'm texting Paul virzi right [ __ ]
now Paul virzi should i do I should wait
right what if this guy takes it back all
right
25 seconds left Case Keenum he's gonna
present his case that he is is the key
numb to them winning sorry what the [ __ ]
I mean they did a bunch for Aaron judge
I can't have fun with Case Keenum stain
that's what I'm gonna do someday you
know when I retire from being a comedian
I'm gonna go stright headlines for
sports pages you know and I'll finally
get to do all my pun jokes that I'm not
allowed to do in a comedy you do a pun
joke in a comedy club you're gonna get a
groan and people can't you do enough of
them people gonna ask for their [ __ ]
money back all right
The Daily News the New York Post all of
these guys they live on it Oh false
start false start everybody's pointing
at everybody else a little disco dancing
uh on the Vikings oh jeez look at that
guy how much this his breath stink
[ __ ] beard he's probably still got
cereal in there oh that wasn't good
that's not the way you that's not the
way you want to start you two-minute
offense I like the Vikings when I was a
kid cos purple was my favorite color
when I was a little kid I wanted to I
wanted to be a painter now like of art I
just wanted to paint houses I thought it
was gonna that would be a cool job and
all right prevent defense they're on the
38 yard line don't take a dump penalty
I just wanted to paint houses and I was
gonna paint everybody's house purple
whether they liked it or not because
that was my favorite color
[Laughter]
so right out of the gate you know I was
a [ __ ] oh Jesus
here we go Paul virzi here we go I'm
actually gonna I'm gonna text it right
now cuz if I'm wrong you guys will I
will put the sound on you'll get to
listen to me delete it dude I [ __ ]
called it called it why is it so much
fun being write about sports it's
probably cuz you just you know I'm so
wrong and the rest of my life just feels
good every once in a while incomplete
it only took [ __ ] two seconds off
alright you know this is gonna be boring
the amount of time this is gonna [ __ ]
take let me read the next goddamn
question is it gonna be another love
letter Oh bill tip on making oatmeal
okay I started eating steel cut oats and
they have this gluey consistency unless
you just keep stirring the [ __ ] thing
he said get an instance the pot and you
could make steel cut oats in like three
to four minutes
they're like $90 on Amazon I should use
honey you see if I can get it for 87 if
you go to your website and click the
link they'll even throw you a little bit
of cash there chief
the [ __ ] is an insta Pont you mean like
a microwave insta pot let me see this
it's like a vaporizer for oatmeal insta
pot I need to Google a [ __ ] picture
of that insta pot that looks like a
complete piece of [ __ ] Oh in stand pot
wait is that what you wrote my losing my
mind where is it
now you wrote insta pot it's instant
instant pot like I'll have this
breakfast made in an instant
oh but and on Amazon it says insta pot
maybe the instant pot is [ __ ] ripping
them off alright what is it it's balling
you on 39 what down is it case Cana back
for a [ __ ] pass throws the ball
incomplete oh boy oh boy oh boy yeah
that's what it's the insta part is 120
bucks so I'm with this is just gonna be
something else in my [ __ ] covered
because I can't wait an extra 26 minutes
of my oats you like how this person was
just trying to help me out I'm still
being a jerk about him I am into I
didn't see that new Matt Damon movie
about downsizing but I am all about that
[ __ ] I just [ __ ] I had a lot of
layoffs in my wardrobe I just sent
everything [ __ ] I'm gonna be like three
pairs of pants one black one blue and
then just one for every [ __ ] moment of
my [ __ ] day oh my god that could not
have just happened they could not have
just happened oh my god I am still I
can't [ __ ] you please the greatest
podcast ever that could not have just
happened how do you let that happen
holy [ __ ] alright wait I'm [ __ ]
believable oh you know what I didn't
save the thing when I texted to virzi I
almost said dude I [ __ ] called it how
did that [ __ ] just happen on the last
play of the game and that he missed him
and knocked his own guy down
you have to be [ __ ] kidding me I have
literally seen it all I cannot [ __ ]
believe that just happened
are you [ __ ] kidding me
exactly Case Keenum oh my god I just
thought when the guy caught a like holy
[ __ ] are they gonna have time to kick a
field goal why won't anybody hug Case
Keenum
look at the wide receiver acted like he
just did something I mean he caught the
ball but that Saints completely [ __ ]
up he act like he faked out that guy he
Wow oh my god I don't know what the name
of that Saint is but I got a feeling
everybody's gonna know that name by
tonight holy [ __ ] I cannot [ __ ]
believe that just happened
that was another mad went through
Pearson caught that [ __ ] ball the
Vikings are finally on the right side of
one of these plays holy [ __ ] oh my god I
cannot [ __ ] believe I cannot [ __ ]
believe that just happened it's
unbelievable
happy for Minnesota but Jesus Christ sad
for the Saints what the [ __ ] now how if
you're that guy in the Saints that
missed the guy completely didn't even
put your [ __ ] arms out and then took
out another player how do you go into
that locker room what do you say what
the [ __ ] do you say oh my god what were
the [ __ ] odds I was gonna be watching
this game the entire time oh Jesus now
the rest got a look we're viewing the
score it's just he didn't step out of
bounds don't take this away from
football fans don't take this away what
did he do we just put his head down
that's like some Pop Warner [ __ ] oh my
god ruling the field is confirmed with
the ref taking a lot of time here he
never gets cheered
we must kick the field goal I just shut
it off I cannot wait a minute I got to
leave it on what if they [ __ ] block
it and scored score a [ __ ] touchdown
right I got to leave that on I can't I
don't believe what I just saw I cannot
[ __ ] believe that how many times have
I said that [ __ ] unbelievable how do
I follow this up with questions I just
did all of that now my next question do
you miss the Prius I swear to god that's
the question oh no they're gonna clear
the field we have to [ __ ] kick the
extra point the Saints are gone now they
got to come out of the locker room can
you imagine if the guy just [ __ ] that
player blocked this extra point and ran
it back for a touchdown that would be
like watching a tosh point-o like you
know when he has the people be able to
do the redemptions without needing tosh
point-o maybe a self-contained episode
alright hang on a second
let me [ __ ] get my password in here
let me read this Prius thing while we're
waiting okay do you miss the Prius what
up Billy Buick I actually love a Buick
back in the day I loved Buicks you know
but when a Cadillac was a Cadillac and a
Buick was like you know you weren't
quite a Cadillac guy I wonder if this
would have put him at least in field
goal range the worst [ __ ] attempt
ever at a [ __ ] the fact that that guy
is a safety oh my god
I don't fight I've seen a lot of [ __ ] I
have seen a lot of [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
anyways do you I know you're 54 years
while driving your Prius built I was
wonder if you still like driving a nicer
vehicle or regret spending the money I'm
in the recovery from buying new vehicles
I wasted money for years on new cars and
never really got any satisfaction from
it the past three years I've been
driving a 2007 Honda Accord awesome and
surprisingly I'm pretty happy with it
yeah dude once you get it paid off it's
a [ __ ] I still have to fight the urge to
buy a new ride often anyways Happy New
Year from down in Alabama I know cuz I
eat I didn't buy a nice car till I could
afford one that's a mistake a lot of
people do you know they're trying to get
some lady's attention or whatever the
[ __ ] it is or they just love cars so
much like if you're really really a car
guy I understand like along the way
you're gonna have like nice cars but I
was always about paying off my house and
getting the bankers off my back I was
into that [ __ ] this is what's [ __ ] up
is the Saints right now they have a
chance a very small chance but they they
have a chance don't they to block the
extra point and returned it for a
touchdown can't that [ __ ] happen
anyways yeah I I was always I was always
way into no debt or working my way
towards having no debt like I I just I
can't stress that enough to young people
when you get like a credit card at all
that [ __ ] it's just like be be really
careful with those things and you can't
like oh this is smart they're just gonna
go for a 2.0 version or just down the
ball so that can't happen there you go
that's smart my dumb ass that's why I
don't coach on any level anyways the
[Music]
yeah I was I just was always into like
just not being in debt you know it just
absolutely paralyzes you and it affects
your ability to go after what you want
to go after I've told this story before
like I kept a day job until I moved to
New York the first three and a half
years I was a comedian probably the last
year well actually it's not true cuz I
was still living at home with my parents
I could have basically you know said hey
can you help support me with my dream
and I could have just been sitting
around the house on just making comedy
money but I continued to work and before
I move down to New York I paid off
everything I paid off my student loans I
paid off my car which died right before
I went to New York and I saved up a
chunk of money and I just moved down to
New York and I was never a ramen noodle
guy but I definitely ate a lot of
[ __ ] rigatoni and spaghetti and [ __ ]
and I just did that so I'm when I
finally got it when I finally bought
myself a nice car I could afford it and
felt like I earned it and yeah I loved
it but I also loved the Prius the priest
is a [ __ ] great car
you know cheapest [ __ ] the [ __ ] own
it's never a problem you can park it
wherever you want no one's trying to
steal a [ __ ] Prius you know I always
joked like you know when once mine was
like eight or nine years old I literally
could leave that thing on with the door
open in the middle of a [ __ ] you know
riot and no one would take it like you
know you know whenever they do the trap
car they try to get people to steal that
car they've never I will be willing to
bet they never did that with the [ __ ]
Prius now I want to know how many of
those Viking fans stuck around you know
some people left you know that they
[ __ ] left and as they were winding
down the [ __ ] stairs they just heard
every going oh my god oh my god then
they had to [ __ ] to run their fat
asses back up there congratulations to
the Vikings holy [ __ ]
the Vikings did not win that game that
was a the biggest fuck-up
I have seen in a long goddamn time drew
brees and once again Drew Brees the
silent assassin nobody knows how good
that guy is and now he's not gonna get
to prove in the NFC Championship game
potentially trying to win a Super both
uh tragedy
all right bulletproof glass [ __ ]
dear Billy dad bought you know that
hurts I was listening to your podcast a
while back where you read someone's
email concerning owning a store with a
bulletproof glass where his grandfather
was almost killed and he was outraged at
the mandate and claimed the person
pushing the bill said bulletproof
windows are racist I just wanted to
point out that it was [ __ ] most
people in this country who get outraged
over things are oftentimes just
misinformed and because we live in a
consumer culture where the customer is
always right no they're not that's
old-school the customer is not right the
customer can go [ __ ] themselves and talk
to a [ __ ] robot on the phone if
you're bleeding to death fresh to the
mindset has transitioned to politicians
saying the citizens are hardworking
honest honorable Americans rather than
saying the truth most citizens are
ignorant entitled tribal mouths tribal
mouth-breathers sir I don't know at what
point in political history politicians
were saying that they never said that
either so you're kind of speaking in in
hyperbole I believe is the expression
but I understand what you're saying
you're trying to build up your point
this is the bill that was proposed
regarding bulletproof windows
I'm not [ __ ] reading all of that it's
regarding restaurants and no other
places of business so that person that
wrote you in fear of having his
bulletproof glass banned is basically an
outrage over nothing Oh in outrage you
know in outrage you mean OD it doesn't
even affect him or his grandfather well
that's good it was never called racist
we want to make sure that there isn't
this sort of indignity in my opinion to
serving food through a plexiglass only
in certain name
what that doesn't make sense well who
you to say it's indignant ah you know
what that's that's sneaky writing right
there you're gonna get offended for
people I don't understand what's going
on here I don't know
it was never called racist we want to
make sure that there isn't this sort of
indignity in my opinion to serving food
through a plexiglass only in a certain
neighborhoods whenever I was doing gigs
in bad neighborhoods and they had that
[ __ ] bulletproof glass I always
looked at it okay heads up keep your
head on a swivel I appreciated it being
there I didn't feel like [ __ ] I don't
know what you're trying to do here but I
I am in favor of hurting some people's
feelings if it keeps people who want to
just have the honest job of working at a
restaurant alive I would be in favor of
it I don't think it's plexiglass is it
plexiglass stops a bullet I don't
[ __ ] know um that's from Philadelphia
Councilwoman Cindy bass all right let's
look up Cindy bass Cindy can be your
friend
310 she's your [ __ ] council man why
does it always take me to [ __ ]
wikipedia now what the [ __ ] where are we
Cindy bass images
Cindy bass appears to be
african-american all right so this
person was saying that she was being
racist now according to some people it's
impossible for a black person to be
ready I don't even know what the [ __ ] is
going on right now I don't know all I
know is if I worked in a goddamn
restaurant and somebody nearby had shot
someone in a restaurant to the point
that somebody felt that there needed to
be some [ __ ] glass up there I would
want it but who the [ __ ] am I to say
what people need in their in their
neighborhood now how the [ __ ] did I get
signed out of that thing hey when it
signs you out it goes you want to make a
report no I don't have time for this
[ __ ]
where's time to do that I was trying to
do a podcast you know oh so no so no it
was never called cable wow I still don't
agree that any type of business should
be mandated to remove a type of security
for whatever it was websites like
steadfast and loyal comm that wrote
bulletproof glass is now racist in their
title however you know what I actually
understand what you say in here because
that type of [ __ ] happens to comedians
all the time where they just you know
they float something out there
Huffington Post and then they try to get
you in trouble or make it more
sensationalized so they can get views
however in the body of the article they
admitted that the Councilwoman never
used those words but of course most
people don't read beyond this article
yeah see I mean that's the internet
there's really no there's no libel
there's no there's none I cannot [ __ ]
I gotta hear what this guy said
God cared God cared that this guy yep
God cared the other guy had too much
devil in him and tell the other that the
safety on the Saints he prayed to the
devil that's what happened and the devil
misled him to tackle err to tackle his
own [ __ ] teammate I know you're a
comedian and not some [ __ ] political
correspondent so it's not like I'm
trying to hold you up to some Barbara
Walters type of standard but I know some
people in your audience forget that and
believe everything they read and
everything they hear that feeds into
what they already believe like you said
I am right calm yeah well dude nobody's
coming to this [ __ ] website to become
informed okay don't put that on me okay
I did not pursue that which is why I
became a comedian all right
I tried this Siri the serious world it
didn't [ __ ] work out for me I failed
miserably
okay failed my wife all right dear Billy
Buddy Guy my wife and I had been married
for a year and a half we both have a
child from prior relationships and a
seventh month old daughter together
she's an angel by the way of course she
is she is latina and I only bring that
up because she fits all the fiery
stereotypes both good in bed she
completes my life with this although
arguments can get very difficult dude I
think you were talking about you
seven-month-old it's [ __ ] hilarious
you went right into that I thought
you're good you're having arguments with
a seven-month-old and she's fiery
there's [ __ ] talking gibberish okay
your wife okay she's latina and I only
bring that up because she fits all these
stereotypes she completes my life all
over both I have some of the same temper
issues that you used to describe
yourself and your bit about kneeling on
the ball when I'm right has paid off
huge so thank you for that yeah I wish I
should probably watch that bit because I
have not been doing that lately I've
been airing it out anyway to cut to the
chase we decided together to fight for
primary custody of my son
the case is very complicated but for the
sake of everyone listening I'll
summarize it with as few details as
possible in family court before
peirong in front of a judge there is a
conference where a meteor mediator tries
everything they can to make sure you can
come to an agreement and avoid a judge
deciding my wife and I had a plan going
in to not cut a deal with my ex at the
conference and hold out for a judge to
rule on custody however I had no idea
the level of pressure that they'd be
able to put on me and I buckled under it
and made a deal for the next year then I
had to go home and explain to my wife
that I had failed our plan I don't know
if you've ever completely disappointed
your woman but this is the worst feeling
in the world well wait a minute she's
gonna judge you because they probably
used your love of your own kid right
against you anyways and as you can
imagine over the past day or so she's
cutting me into me it's just about every
opportunity for all the little failures
and I can see it right in her eyes that
her man had a moment of weakness and
didn't come through in the clutch worse
is that she absolutely hates my ex and
feels like I let her get the better of
me us yeah I kind of a feeling yeah okay
all right
oh geez you're in the middle of that
you're in the middle of two ladies you
have ever disappointed your woman with a
grand [ __ ] about every three days I
guess a good boxing analogy is that my
hands are down and I don't know how long
to let her continue jabbing at me until
I put them back up thanks and go [ __ ]
yourself
I wouldn't take another ounce of [ __ ]
from her I need to sit down and talk to
her and be like wait a minute I'm trying
to get my kid back I'm going back with
all of this emotional weight let me make
sure this is you decided together to get
primary custody of your son now whose
idea was that was that totally yours or
was the the hatred your wife has of your
ex-wife plate into the thing I don't
know dude I don't know what's going on
but it sounds when it went into my head
okay now no notice no that everything
that you say is now perverted cuz went
into my brain as I say once you say
something it's not
what you said anymore it's cut with the
other person's experiences it's like
drugs that have been stepped on what you
said was pure cocaine now it's in my
head and there's all this xlx and
[ __ ] laxatives getting [ __ ] put in
it all I hear is that your wife your
current wife presents your previous
[ __ ] wife and she's doing that woman
thing where they don't solve things with
their fists they try to [ __ ] make
they just do that thing when they try to
make the other woman as miserable as
they possibly can and she knows probably
how much it would break your ex-wife's
heart to lose primary custody of your
son
and she really wanted to do that to her
because that would make her feel better
and more secure in your relationship I
don't [ __ ] know I have no idea -
there's too many [ __ ] variables here
but I wouldn't take an ounce of [ __ ] if
I had a son from a previous marriage and
you know I was trying to do what you
were doing and then I caved under that
pressure my wife would understand it if
she ever gave me [ __ ] I would be stunned
and then I would [ __ ] read her the
riot act and I would go out to a bar and
have a couple of cold ones there that's
what I would do okay now I get into a
lot of arguments in my relationship so
you probably don't want to listen to me
I have no professional background okay
I'm the type of man that once that
already types out dude I called it with
25 seconds left and [ __ ] jinx is the
Saints maybe it was my fault all right I
don't know what the [ __ ] that was but
you can't say it wasn't compelling if
you're a football fan everybody else I
apologize - go [ __ ] yourselves and I'll
check in on ya on Thursday